-Welcome back, everyone.
Seth Meyers is joining us today.
-Great to be here.
-Ah, thank you for
being here, bud.
-Yeah.
-During this writers' strike,
you also started
another podcast.
-Yes.
-I love this one.
With your brother, Josh.
-Yes.
-Who I love. And, by the way,
give him my best.
-I will. He used to do stuff
with you on the show,
on "Late Night."
-Yes.
-And, yeah, it's called "Family
Trips with the Meyers Brothers."
We had this idea for years
and we decided the strike
was a good time
to get it off the ground.
-Why "Family Trips"?
-So, we talked to,
you know, celebrities,
and we only talked to them
about the trips they took
when they were kids.
And it's really fun,
because you realize
what a great equalizer it is.
Very few of the celebrities
you know and love
had money when they were kids.
And it's just a lot --
And also, you know,
for Josh and I, we grew up
in the '70s and early '80s,
and so many people like us
took trips where they were
just in the back of
a station wagon, no seat belts.
Nobody even thought
about seat belts.
-Yeah.
-The amount of kids --
It's like,
"My parents
would put down a mattress.
We had a card table.
And we'd slide around."
-Then just random gamblers
back there with the
strangers you
picked up on the --
-We'd pick up dealers.
-Yeah.
Go play poker with my kids.
Yeah, exactly. Smart.
-But it's fun,
and you just realize --
Especially
the more trips go wrong,
I feel like the more
they enter the family lore,
and those disaster trips
are the ones
you talk about for years
and years with your family
because you survived them
and it brought you all closer.
And so it's nice talking to
people about all those things --
-Who do you got
coming up on that podcast?
-We got Nate Bargatze.
I know a huge Nate Bargatze fan
right here.
-I love that dude.
-Nick Offerman's coming up.
-Mulaney?
-John Mulaney is coming up.
-Yeah, okay.
And, so, it's just a --
It's a full delight.
You're going to do it, right?
-I'm so in. I can't wait.
-We're podcast bros now.
You got to do it.
-Dude, we have to do it.
-We're podcast bros.
-I already got my trip
planned out. I can't wait.
-Great.
-I have all the gear.
-Yeah, you do have
all the gear.
-What am I going to do
with all this gear?
-I know.
-Kimmel was like -- He's like,
"If you're doing this podcast,
I already ordered this mixer,
these headphones,
I got this microphone thing."
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
I don't know what --
But he gave us, like,
an Amazon link.
-I wanted to talk about --
I almost forgot.
The best thing about
"Strike Force Five" is,
we all -- Like,
we all got better as we went,
because the first room --
You did the first two episodes
in a room, and I've never seen
Jimmy look hotter.
He chose -- And, again,
we started in August.
There was terrible ventilation,
and just it was like
watching you melt.
-Well, I didn't know what room
to do the podcast in.
Nothing was really quiet.
And so I went --
We have, like, a guest cottage.
So I went to this cottage thing,
and there was a loud cricket
that was so loud, I go,
"They're going to think --"
And I would have to stomp
on the floor,
and then it would be quiet.
I go, "I can't do this
for the whole --"
-Wait. The cricket would be
quiet if you stomped?
So it was a very --
It was a respectful cricket.
-Trained cricket. Yeah.
I don't want to work
with the amateur crickets.
Yeah. He's famous.
He might -- Jiminy?
-Oh, Jiminy?!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's pretty famous.
He's been in a couple films.
-Oh, my God!
-Yeah, no big deal.
I don't want to name-drop,
but I hang out with cartoons.
-Wow!
-You don't know me?
My whole world is car--
-That was the Jiminy Cricket?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're old, old, old buddies.
-And you didn't want to
bring him on the podcast?
-Yeah, what is he going to talk
about? Pinocchio?
-Yes!
-Nah, come on. Come on.
He's not in the new one.
So, I went to this room,
and there was
no air-conditioning,
and I was just shoved in
so I could get out
of everyone's way.
And it was so hot.
-Yeah.
-And I go, "Oh, my gosh."
And we did two episodes.
And we were just trying to
figure out --
So, I think it
was like four hours.
-It was long.
The first day was long.
-But then here's
why I was -- I wasn't mad,
but it was making me laugh.
Everything was making me laugh.
But because I was like,
"I got to get out of here,
because I'm going to die."
I mean, my face was red.
I was -- So, I texted everybody
on Strike Force.
-So, this is the craziest thing.
So, Jimmy is talking
to four of us on --
It's not a live podcast,
so anything he says
we could just edit out.
-I know, I know, I know, I know.
-But, instead,
he chooses to text us.
-Well, I didn't think
you were gonna read it,
so I texted everyone, "Hey,
I got to get out of here, man."
Like, "Wrap it up.
Let's go, man."
I'm like -- And then --
-Colbert immediately was like,
"Hey, I just got a text
from Jimmy.
He's got to go."
And we're like, "What?"
It'd be like if you were at
dinner with one other person
and you texted them,
"How much longer
is this dinner going to go?"
-Oh, my God.
Totally busted me on that.
So, you and Oliver
are doing stand-up together.
-Yeah, John Oliver and I --
we're going to do
New Year's Eve in Las Vegas.
-Whoo!
-Very exciting.
-That's going to be fun.
-And I'm also very excited.
I'm doing a fundraising show
in New Hampshire, in Manchester.
That's my home state.
-That's right.
-It's a fundraiser for a couple
of great organizations --
Granite State Children's
Alliance and CASA.
So if you live
in the Granite State,
come check it out, because
it's a really special night.
-You're a good man.
We always love it
when you stop by.
That's my "Strike Force Five"
buddy right there.
Seth Meyers, everybody.
-Here we go!
-Stay tuned.
"Late Night with Seth Meyers"
airs weeknights,
including Wednesdays,
right after "The Tonight Show."
It's also available on Peacock.
Stick around.
We'll be right back, everybody.